after an uneven final season comprised
of only six episodes fans were excited
concerned and downright desperate to see
how the game of Thrones saga would
finally end from the Iron Throne to the
fate of Westeros and the final showdown
between Daenerys and Jon Snow here's
what the ending of Game of Thrones means
not just for the final season but for
the entire series
beware spoilers are coming after the
burning of King's Landing in the
previous episode several main characters
wandered through the brutal aftermath
material lannister the hand of the Queen
looking stricken as he walks down ruins
streets and sees the bodies of those
Daenerys burned without mercy as he and
Jon Snow survey the destruction John and
Tyrion separately set off to meet the
Queen John's journey finds him at odds
with grey worm over the execution of
Lannister soldiers but soon after Tyrion
sets off on his own he makes a
horrifying discovery in a truly
heartbreaking moment
Tyrion finds the bodies of his brother
and sister and breaks down amid the
rubble with the rest of his house
literally entombed Tyrion finds himself
suddenly alone and in that moment his
resolve to defy his queen strengthens
later as the Dothraki and unsullied
celebrate their victory Daenerys makes a
grand entrance riding atop drogon and
landing in a perfect shot with her
silhouetted by his wings while she gives
a full-throated victory speech in which
she praises her army for taking down a
tyrant and claiming the city as their
own viewers know the truth Dany is no
better than the tyrant she aims to
replace in fact she's probably a lot
worse as she announces her plans to
prolong the war and conquer the rest of
the world Daenerys has always bent
toward justice but with this
proclamation it seems as if she's
finally gone too far and even her most
trusted advisors seemed frightened by
her endless hunger for power in the
aftermath of the siege on King's Landing
during which Tyrion begged his queen to
show mercy to those who couldn't defend
themselves it seems as if the last
remaining lannister could no longer
bring himself to follow Daenerys and
have seen her for what she really is or
at least what she's ultimately become
Daenerys is already furious with Tyrion
after finding out that he freed Jaime
which ultimately doesn't even matter
considering that Jaime and Cersei are
both dead but Tyrion has his own
grievances with the mother of drag
as they confront each other atop a
ruined King's Landing he admits that he
freed his brother but reminds her that
she decimated an entire city moments
later he tosses aside the badge that
identifies him as the hand of the Queen
Daenerys immediately has him arrested
but his point is made
marking yet another advisor who leaves
her side when she needs them the most
for transformation into a new version of
her father the mad king who killed
anyone who displeased him is complete as
Tyrion sits in captivity awaiting his
certain execution he's visited by a
visibly torn Jon Snow who despite his
allegiance to Daenerys still obviously
trusts Tyrians Council Jon defends
Daenerys at burst saying that though he
can't condone what happened the war is
finally over but Tyrion persists
reminding Jon that Daenerys isn't even
close to finish and the only way she can
achieve our ultimate goal is through
even more death and destruction on a
global scale
Tyrion also reminds Jon that he once had
the power to do with Daenerys did
specifically to ride atop a dragon and
destroy an entire city and he never
would
before she sacked King's Landing
Daenerys destruction often seemed
entirely righteous like when she freed
slaves and killed their masters but as
Tyrion points out the murder of
countless innocent men women and
children can't possibly be defended and
at this point the Dragon Queen will stop
at nothing to achieve her goals though
Tyrion recognizes that love is more
powerful than reason he still does
everything in his power to convince Jon
of the path ahead you've tried to
protect people who's the greatest threat
to the people now Jon the true heir to
the throne having received wise counsel
from the hand knows that there's only
one move left to finally end the war
once and for all John finds Daenerys in
the throne room admiring the throne
she's worked so hard to win as he asked
her why she murdered children in the
streets of the capital she tries to
entice him with her vision of the new
world the two of them can build together
as they embrace John proclaims that
Daenerys will always be his queen just
when it seems like all hope for peace is
lost he stabs her folding her and
weeping this is the moment the series
has been building towards since the
beginning Ned Stark lost his head for
being too honorable in the end John Snow
betrayed his honor in order to save it
he made the impossible
choice killing his lover and queen to
whom he pledged his eternal loyalty for
the greater good of his family and the
world after John becomes the queen
Slayer all is silent for a moment until
drogon reappears coming face to face
with John in a frightening moment when
it seems like the last remaining
Targaryen might immediately face justice
for killing the mother of dragons
however dro gods anguish over the death
of his mother is directed not at John
but it's something entirely different
specifically the Iron Throne which he
torches into a melted pile of slag and a
stream of fire the ultimate symbol of
power and Westeros is completely
destroyed Daenerys has always referred
to her dragons as her children and her
final moments with drogon our heartfelt
as he tries to nudge her awake and
screams in pain for his lost mother
after demolishing the throne once and
for all
drogon gently lifts Daenerys off the
ground and flies away with her safely
ensconced in his claws making for a
fitting end to Daenerys isarc she was
reborn with all three of her dragons and
even in death she remains a part of her
only remaining child
moreover drogon identifies Danny's true
killer without uttering a word it wasn't
John who was responsible for the end of
her life instead it was her unending
quest to seek the Iron Throne itself
it's like Cersei said way back in season
one when you play the game of Thrones
you win will you die
there is no middle ground since the
beginning the throne has represented
death it was composed of the weapons of
the Kings enemies and men and women
fought and killed for a chance to sit on
it Daenerys always wanted to break the
wheel now the drogon has destroyed the
Iron Throne the wheel and Westeros has
finally been broken weeks after Daenerys
is death Tyrion is let out of his cell
to face a new council made up of
familiar characters alongside a few
faces who have been absent from the show
for several seasons the unsullied have
taken King's Landing and are holding
John and Tyrion captive and Tyrion must
not only argue his case against grey
worm but for the entire Council but
before Tyrians fate can be decided the
lords and ladies of Westeros must choose
a new monarch as a group debates who
should rule next Tyrion has asked
whether or not he wants the job he
describes himself as the worst possible
choice
no one really argues his points in order
to explain who he does have in mind
however Tyrion begins by telling the
assembled that what unites everybody is
the power of a story that identifying
the person he says has the best story
bran Stark who is journeyed beyond the
wall and back to become the all-seeing
three-eyed Raven
everybody seems a bit stunned by this
unexpected nomination
except for bran but now that he's the
three-eyed Raven looking surprise isn't
really his thing but once tyrion points
out that because bran can't have
children the leader of Westeros will be
chosen rather than receive it by
birthright he receives a unanimous vote
after everything the starts have lived
through the eldest surviving Starks son
is named bran the broken first of his
name in exchange brand chooses Tyrion as
his new hand bringing his arc to a
fitting conclusion as far as his own arc
is concerned Fran's ascension to the
throne may seem surprising given the
path his story has taken throughout the
series moreover in this final season
bran doesn't actually do much aside from
glower at other characters from his
chair and say weird things but if you
remember the very first episode of the
series bran has a front row seat to an
execution carried out by his father the
scene is meant as a lesson for bran and
the rules of Justice and leadership
namely that duty and honor justifies
violence and death but now that bran
will take over as king of Westeros in
the wake of Daenerys war crimes it seems
like a sure bet that he'll have taken
his father's lesson and will apply the
inverse mercy fairness and justice trump
duty and honor and are the only true
path to peace and life since the
beginning of the season Sansa who has
established herself as a fair leader as
well as a sharp and shrewd strategist as
bristled at the thought of the North
falling under anyone's rule throughout
Daenerys reign she argued for the north
to maintain its status as an independent
territory with its own monarchs and
wardens when John told her about his
true parentage she immediately shared
the information with Tyrion clearly
hoping to keep control of the north by
not only keeping a tyrant from taking
the throne but by putting a half Stark
Regent in power while that plan didn't
pan out
Sansa ultimately made sure the north was
taken care of during the council meeting
Sansa is hesitant to cast a vote in
favor of brand and as she turns to her
brother and tells him that she loves
and that she's sure he'll be a great
king she insists at the north remain its
own territory and brand grants her
request
thanks to Sansa the North can keep its
identity and its independence and since
the North always remembers its citizens
will certainly remember what the lady of
Winterfell did to protect them as for
the rest of the characters each of them
is seen off properly with arcs completed
stories told and journeys finally
finished grey worm sets off for Natha
lone still smarting after losing both
Masson day and his queen brahne returns
to claim his lordship of Highgarden and
becomes master of coin and brand's
administration planked by a small
Council that includes Brienne Davos Sam
and Tyrion Podrick Payne now brands
attendance has been knighted and made a
member of the Kingsguard since viewers
last saw him not only are several
stories completed but some characters
write out stories of their own making
sure the people they lost won't be
forgotten after finding Jamie's
unfinished entry in the book listing
Westeros II Nights Brienne completes it
herself capping it off by writing died
protecting his Queen meanwhile Sam
presents the council with a book written
by one of the maesters called what else
a Song of Ice and Fire in an obvious and
rather heavy-handed reference to the
book series by George RR martin on which
the series is based
unlike martin series however this book
appears to be finished Jon for murdering
the Queen is banished back into the
Nights Watch a symbolic move and the
only way the council can seem to broker
peace with the unsullied and get them to
relinquish their hold on the city upon
returning to Castle black
Jon reunites with torment as well as a
large group of wildlings and his
direwolf ghost who despite missing an
ear is thrilled to see his master once
again in the end the series closes with
shots of the family with which it began
the Starks who have scattered to various
corners of Westeros and beyond Sansa is
coronated at Winterfell
proudly taking her seat as the citizens
of the north raised their swords and
cheer for the new queen in the north
Arya boards a ship headed for the
unknown lands west of Westeros sailing
under the stark banner on a quest to
learn what lies beyond the part of the
world where their Maps end meanwhile
John sets out from Castle black with
tormund ghost and a group of wildlings
in tow as they begin their journey to
the far north some green
can be seen peeking out from underneath
the thick layers of snow throughout game
of thrones' run audiences have always
been told that winter is coming but now
that the night king is no more and a new
age has begun in Westeros it seems as if
the show's long winter may finally be
coming to an end
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]